let will tell it from Taylor Gang Uzi
was almost tailor gang if you let will
tell it yeah how does he tell it he just
said we almost had Uzi I think it was
like it would have been like a
generation now Taylor Gang thing I don't
know was that ever like close to
actually happening because you guys
you're on every [__] Wiz Khalifa tour
that ever happens yeah so that's a
family thing shout out to shout out to
Will and Nate and the guys and all those
guys was that ever like a thing that was
close to that was it was a family
situation I mean basically you know
first time I ever heard Uzi by the way
was in Ty Dolla signs dressing or hotel
room in Boston like [__] I don't know
how many years ago he was just playing a
[__] on town oh what the [__] is this Ty
was yeah yeah so vert you know I took
vert on tour with me during every summer
I go on tour with
came out because I actually met him
during our first tour together we we did
um in 2014 one that one that I did with
Wiz and then the next year uh we went
out with uh whiz and Fall Out Boy and I
brought vert on the road with me so he
would come out on my set
um and perform what you want and you
know him and him and uh wiz just you
know established a relationship in a
bond and you know whiz put him on a
record very early on
um and you know like so
in that sense like you know he was
family he was he was like he was like
teller gang you know but it wasn't like
a it wasn't like a paperwork situation I
think he might have had a Taylor game
changed he did so what happened was I
think at
um the first very Oozy Christmas we did
in Philly
um whiz gave him a teller gang chain on
the stage now mind you this is this is
still very early on when people one
didn't even know Uzi was signed to DJ
Drama Don Cannon let alone know what
generation now was so that literally was
kind of like the way that the name
generation now even got some traction
because it came out like Uzi vert signs
to Taylor Gang right you know of course
those are our brothers that's family but
we were like uh this is not exactly not
the whole story yeah he signed a
generation now so then it turned into
like wait what's generation now so it
kind of like in a sense kind of worked
out in our favor because it was a way
for us to start to Brand generation now